hello from camera cam so these are
little Swag Bags that we got at check-in
so let's open them up and see what's
inside so first things first is this
wandered bag I'm such a huge fan of
wondered also got this cute little
keychain this camera cam themed a little
bit biased about this one it's the
iJustine pouch with a custom little
camera Camp pin on it
we've got an iJustine USBC cable Gerald
HDMI cable we have the Mondo ties
absolutely obsessed with these they're
Condor blue camera caps we also have
this little top handle which is so
awesome super cool we've got our camera
cam San Diego logo
got some Sony link buds s since we are
in San Diego it's kind of like a beach
theme so we've got a little beachy towel
we've also got our camera Camp wristband
oh I also forgot uh check this out it's
a viori hoodie it's so good I love it